it looks very tense I'm very tense yeah
trust me you have not seen test it's not
me at all
[Music]
it's comical for me like very comical
when someone says that you already know
they are in their feelings during their
first time meeting Bilal goes head to
head with shaida's best friend uterus in
this awkward back and forth that felt
like two High School valedictorians
having a petty argument I'm smarter than
you but I don't think we should be so
presumptuous
sounds like you're um
what's the word they say in London I
don't know what you're trying to say
if the word is it oh nosy
yeah things get pretty tense and might I
say a tad bit weird like give me your
energy right now
are you looking
it's very
just different we'll get into what led
to that ping pong war of words and I
can't wait to hear your take on it all
he's making me lose my I can talk to me
on this hon well you can lose your
appetite I'm trying to compose myself
just give me a second that's that type
of heated where you're looking at the
menu but can't read a thing all you see
is red let's get into it
foreign
fam it's melicia a lot went down this
episode before we get into shy down
below I need to update you on Usman and
Kim and Michael and Angela first let's
start with Usman
[Music]
his mom is looking like wow this boy got
me out here on camera
he and his mom gonna meet the young
woman she wants him to marry this
episode and at first it was crickets
between Usman and his potential wife
but then he started spinning game
yeah well I was even watching my voice
okay
this young woman whose name is farida is
18. and she says she's heard of Usman
before she's listened to his music and
she's quote excited to marry him but
halfway through that conversation Usman
did something that was very commendable
and I'm not gonna lie I didn't expect it
from him he told farida about Kim he
didn't say her name directly but he said
he's in a relationship with a woman who
can't give him children Usman then goes
on to ask her if she's willing to be his
second wife and allow him to marry Kim
first
and farida said no
I I guess yeah surely no although that's
not exactly what Usman wanted to hear he
asked her for her number so they can
continue to talk and get to know one
another now after that little meet and
greet Usman tells his mom it went well
but he's in love with Kim fast forward
it's Usman and Kim's last day in his
hometown and usman's brother calls him
saying that his mom wants to talk once
they all sit down his brother pulls out
a contract for Kim to sign either who's
better Kimberly have no right to
anyone's Properties or money unless
willingly
if a couple decides to move to United
States of America Kimberly must allow
who's been to visit his family Nigeria
every quarter
Kimberly mess a lot who's been to Mary
young lady in the future to Neighborhood
Yep this contract is usman's mom giving
him and Kim her blessing
[Music]
Kim can now be the first wife
I don't know whether to be happy for her
or what this is the life you imagine for
yourself or I don't know hell no I think
sometimes I'm learning myself in
relationships sometimes we hold on to
stuff because it's comfortable and we
like the idea of it but it's really not
what we want you know
um I um I have I love who's been an F to
let this happen I love him enough to let
it happen I have learned that I have to
pick my battles this wedding is going to
be interesting I wonder will Kim send
Jamal show up he loves his mama I'm sure
he will but you never know all right
moving on I'm not gonna get too much
into Michael and Angela just know she
finally got him to delete his Instagram
after all of this
I want you to take that Instagram down
and keep it down I am not taking it down
and that is it
[ __ ]
[Music]
remember the main reason Angela flew to
Nigeria and popped up on Michael
unannounced is because he wouldn't take
down his Instagram so I guess his
mission accomplished for her I've
learned to understand which my wife
Angie I just have to pick my battle but
nevertheless I want my voice to be heard
I need to do something to put my foot
down because if I don't stand up for
myself now Angela is going to control
everything even when I get to the state
it's gonna be hell yet you can you can
walk toward the fiery Gates Michael
shaida and Bella
for a few months now and aside from
launching her yoga business in Kansas
City their biggest issue on the table is
that shaida is ready to have a baby and
Bilal is not
but according to shada's doctor at the
age of 37 she doesn't have much time to
wait so if they want to have a baby they
need to start trying now in the meantime
below are knocking something else off of
her bucket list they take a trip to New
York City one of shaida's dream
destinations it's
it's loud
it's very loud I love the smell
this sounds just like a a posey in the
Caribbean we call it a posey because of
poses what's that as a place we store
urine
yeah
I guess that's part of the experience is
it it is okay
that was cute while they're in the city
that never sleeps they also plan to meet
up with shaida's best friend utris who
is in town from London below will be
meeting her for the first time I'm
excited to see you just tonight
I can't wait for you to me tell
yep the loud one that yep
that is his go-to he sang so much by
saying so little
yeah I can't wait too now that is hard
to believe Blau I think this trip would
be really good
this is a really good time for us to get
away
kind of going a little Adventure
you know have some romantic times just
me and you I'm hoping that when I leave
this trip inshallah that I'm pregnant
like I hope that we I could have some
news like
the doctor told us to try so we could at
least see if something happens you know
Wanna Have Some Fun
are you wanna like
bring baggage with you
so something I'm learning right now is
the practice of non-attachment some of
you might be familiar with it but I feel
like it could help in shaida's case
because unfortunately this approach
I'm hoping that when I leave this trip
inshallah that I'm pregnant as we can
see it's just not working without going
too much into it from what I've grasped
so far practicing non-attachment is
about allowing someone to be how they
are without trying to change them it's
allowing a situation to be how it is
even if it's different from what you
want it to be as long as you're not in
Danger let's be clear essentially
non-attachment is about giving yourself
some space to loosen your grip on the
things that you desire and giving
yourself permission to be happy by
focusing on what you have instead of
focusing so much on what you don't now I
know Shada is racing against time which
can cause some anxiety but maybe giving
herself a few weeks to practice just
allowing what is can take some of the
pressure off of that romance and Boop
one day she gets to Below in the mood
and it's about making love and not
making a baby and the baby happens
it's worth a try you'd be surprised at
the Miracles that take place when you
stop stressing and focusing so hard on
something
things tend to fall into place
flower for the lady there you go all
right let's get back to the show Bilal
is suited and booted and Shada is
glowing as they hit the streets of New
York City
wow babe it's perfect you like it I love
it everybody's singing dancing
Shadow did tell us that Bilal is
romantic I bet she feels like a princess
better yet a queen
this is like the Pinnacle of romance
epitome of Romans don't want this day to
end like I have the perfect Rose yeah
the perfect guy the perfect guy nice I
thought I heard you say that we're in
Times Square I'm with you we're gonna
see utris Bilal gets nervous or
something when he hears uterus's name
look at his face in Times Square I'm
with you we're gonna see uterus and it
will be us
doing grown people of business in bed
I'm I'm high five up top
produce something called a baby
uh let's go meet YouTubers
that good old non-attachment can turn
that pretty frown upside down
we're in New York City and so many
things to see we're in the heart of
everything uh we're shy she's still
focused on one thing and she thinks that
we're gonna make this trip about making
a baby which is not the case I hope
dinner with utris will take just take
our mind off of you know the baby thing
you know even it just for a little while
bilal's wish came true because instead
of Shadow worrying about the baby she
was worried about him and utris getting
along is this your friend here
I'm good
you start to feel the tension between
below and uterus build seconds after
they meet
hello pleasure to meet you she's from
utris pleasure nice to meet you nice to
meet you talking a lot about you I'm
sure hopefully good things
let's see about that uterus then goes on
to tell the camera her main concern
about shaida's relationship with Bilal
has never been married before so she's
coming from like
a very innocent Place into someone's
life and I really kind of want to make
sure he understands her background where
she's coming from and what she needs
right now being in America here with him
before we go any further I'm curious
do you already think uterus is
overstepping boundaries or do you think
she's just being a good best friend
let me know so you chose what do you
think about my husband
well it's a bit early still I just have
to say okay
something about you married or something
meeting you first you know I still
haven't forgiven you for that that's an
interesting comment wow Bilal is on
guard
it turns out while I thought utris was
kind of joking something about you
married her something meeting you first
you know I still haven't forgiven you
for that she wasn't normally like I
always introduce her to my friends you
know like my significant other and stuff
like that
she observes and stuff like that so
that's why I'm saying I need to have
that one-to-one with you find out where
you're about and stuff like that with
your vows and
when you think of my best friend
how do you feel about that how do I feel
about having a conversation
um how do you feel about having a
conversation with you oh but I was doing
that salesman thing Patrick was talking
about he is an amazing salesman you know
what to say when to say you know how
when you say something how that person's
gonna react you know how to drop your
tone you know how to get people engaged
now I still don't think it's fair to say
he does it in every situation but the
power move was pretty clear here how do
you feel about having a conversation
I really want to know how you feel about
me asking questions about your
relationship and your marriage with my
friends
you know at least she's asking how you
feel about me asking questions about
your relationship and your marriage with
my friends
um well
uh why are you hesitating okay this is
getting weird well sometimes a
relationship is between usually a two
individuals
so sometimes there are certain things
you may not want to discuss with
everybody who don't who's not in that
um
not really about you oh you just felt
that shade run through her body
it's about to go south as you can see
based off Beatrice's face hello relax
you want me to relax yeah
I will very relaxed
because you like you look like he was
really getting angry I was actually yeah
because I think you're being really mean
and really rude
[Music]
I was answering yes questions
was it hot yeah it was very tense I'm
very tense yeah trust me you have not
seen test not me at all below and utris
the wrong energy in my opinion utris
definitely came in strong but it would
have been would have been nice to see
loud be the bigger person by placing his
ego to the side and choosing not to meet
uterus's intensity at the end of the day
I think she's trying to be a good friend
she doesn't have the best approach or
attitude but she clearly has concerns
about below and shot his relationship
out of love for shaida and that
shouldn't be something below takes
personally are you okay oh great yeah
this is comical for me like very comical
but I don't think we should be so
presumptuous oh big word Bilal what are
you coming back with sounds like you're
um
what's the word they say in London I
don't know what are you trying to say
it's the word is it oh nosy
[Music]
[Applause]
no that's it yeah really because that's
naughty
you said it
that's interesting I cannot wait to see
how y'all feel about this back and forth
we're only 10 minutes into the
conversation and Bella is making me feel
uncomfortable I don't I don't know what
I would have done utris goes on to say
that she's worried Shadow is looking
over some of bilal's personality traits
that may be a problem in the future
which is interesting because earlier in
the episode Shadow said uterus and Bilal
have very similar personalities Bilal
and nutrients they are both strong Alpha
personalities
so yeah choosing basically I'm putting
my nose but it's not meant to me I want
my best friend about your best friend
no
in my opinion just because you're her
best friend does not mean you can ask
anything you want
we're grown and Shadow and Bilal are
married they are already husband and
wife that should be respected I sit down
with her father I sit down with her
mother
all of her sisters but you didn't sit
down with me yeah best friend
she's really upset about that here's the
thing anybody want questions
I would say something if I intend on
saying it you sound like you're being
very invasive
that you have things you don't want me
to ask you could have been uncomfortable
because you don't know where I'm gonna
go with the conversation hmm sounds like
a good read I'm sure the last thing
below wants to talk about with uterus is
him and Shadow having a baby and with
that being one of Shadow's main concerns
I'm sure as her best friend uterus
planned on bringing it up I'm a very
confident person so didn't have anything
to hold
absolutely not okay good
how much more Awkward can this get try
to what did I say that your husband such
bad energy I can't remember what she
said like honestly talking
um it's funny because
your demeanor
you know your energy like even your
energy right now energy now are you
looking um it's very
just different great way to put it it is
different it was more so like who's this
guy you know not to even like
I'm sure that she's probably picked out
a really good guy oh let me get a chance
that I'm thinking she didn't because it
could die well you I didn't assume
anything you said it out of your mouth
thanks Larry defensive but I'll tell
shaida that if utriss is truly her best
friend uterus will know all of the
wonderful things he does for her which
you should be happy
are you saying basically that because
you do things for her then
it's like I should be thankful because
if nobody else would have done it for
her now I understand how that rubbed her
the wrong way instead of allow talking
about what he does for shaida I don't
see why he didn't open up and talk about
how he feels about shaida that being
said uterus is a little bit too invested
in Shadow and bilal's relationship for
me I'm all for ride or die friends but
this is just a bit too much I don't know
if utris feels like she has to take care
of shaida or what but let's bring the
intensity level down it makes it seem as
if there's something deeper going on I'm
happy for my people that I'm that I love
damn what are you ordering yeah you just
what are you ordering because I wanna I
wanna go ahead and order
he's making me lose my I can talk to me
on this hand well you can lose your
appetite
I'm trying to compose myself just give
me a second
well this became way too dramatic the
episode ends with uterus telling the
cameras that Bilal comes off as entitled
it's not as if basically
you've given her your last kidney
do you know what I mean and next week
below and you try to meet one on one and
she brings up him and shaida having a
baby
what if Shadow was to tell you that
she's pregnant in six months time our
friends with God
she could forget to take over the
control pills themselves if she's still
taking them that is an approach
friends friends you gotta love them you
do all right 90 day fans fam make sure
you stick with ET because we are
covering it all I will see you next time
[Music]